when we think of the Queen we think of
her beautiful family and of course her
royal pups mother-daughter we're taking
a look at the royal history of the
Queen's corgis
the Queen loves porgy so she's had
corgis her whole life and they are very
much associated with the British family
she's had 30 to be exact the Queen
received her first pup when she was just
seven a Pembroke Welsh Corgi she named
Dukey and while a few have had pretty
standard titles like Monty and Susan
there's been a handful with names of the
more saucy variety like candy sugar and
honey the royal dogs have travelled the
world with her she even snuck one on her
honeymoon they played a starring role
alongside James Bond in the 2012 Olympic
opening ceremonies they have the run of
the castle
[Music]
heck they eat meals fit for a king
the Royal pups are reportedly served
everything from beef to rabbit which is
whipped up by a gourmet chef and
basically served to them on a silver
platter the bowls are leftovers from the
palace get cheese I presume you know
battered silver dish here and silver
cracked piece of porcelain there but
don't get in their way or you might get
nipped and I've seen the way the corgis
gets hold off when they're in trouble so
you know I don't want to go that a
policeman the Royal clock winder and a
chauffeur can attest to that the Queen
of England is one of my clients the prop
specific problem that I went to attend
to with her was her cookies at the time
she had nine bullfighting
according to dog psychologist roger
Mugford the Queen's corgis were in the
Royal dog house during the time of
Prince Charles and Princess Diana's
divorce fights the dogs quickly when
you're distracted by the affairs of
state and and other things going on
within the family as they were that time
but while the royal canines haven't
always earned themselves the best
reputation there's been at least one
person they've fallen head over paws for
33 has been bought absolutely just
laying on my feet sadly the Queen's last
Court willow died in April she was a
descendant of Susan remember the pup
Elizabeth sneaked on her honeymoon they
don't mind being popped with other
people I mean my grandma I've got
wonderful lady at Windsor who keeps him
when I'm away willow was believed to be
part of the 14th generation in the line
and her death marked the end of an era
for the Queen who reportedly stopped
breeding corgis after her mother's death
in 2002 minute this monk mother daughter
the Queen is getting up there in age
herself and it said she doesn't want to
leave any young dog behind but never
fear the palace is not without canine
the Queen still has two door keys Vulcan
and candy otherwise known as Corgi
dachshund mixes we want to know what do
you think of the four legged Royals and
what would you name the next royal
doggie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]